what inspired you to act like that that
seems like such a i was always an artist
inside i was always an artistic kid i i
wrote i painted i drew from the time i
was like little and um even like gi joe
and star wars like
i would i would just can i would wake up
and continue the story and continue the
story and create these scenarios in my
mind and anybody who would sit there and
listen to me i would tell you the
stories and then that kind of led into
like you know i found like um you know
like role-playing games and i started
running games for my friends which is
basically being a showrunner i would
write the story and then my friends
would show up uh with their characters
and then they would play the characters
in my show and i would kind of run the
show for which you still do you're a big
dungeons i got back into it why work for
d d so i started working for them about
seven years ago as a company so i mean
working for them why i don't i'm not
like a like a fan boy i i got hired um
because i knew so much about their
product i knew more about their product
than most of the people who work there
so they started hiring me to help
consult but how do they know you know
that much about dungeons directly if you
spend 10 minutes with me and you know
what dnd is you'll you'll figure it out
okay so
sophie has told me this she says like i
know i have a lot of friends i don't
gamble i don't play games i don't i'm
not good in sports i'm really not good
at anything what do you do
other than make tons of money and no i'm
not even i'm doing this for free yeah
but
but the the thing about it is you know i
i i would live part time in santa monica
and we would uh walk by the comic book
bookstore and on like and i i think i
mentioned this to sophia i said i walked
by and i looked in the window like on
friday night and there was like every
i'm trying to be uh politically correct
but every possible nerd yeah
they're standing there with a weird hat
their cards
doing things sitting there seriously not
our female insight no no and they're all
gathered around the table and this
seemed to be their life and i was always
fascinated by them and i i think i told
the story at the panel one and sophia
goes that's what my husband does yeah
you go with with who and you have like a
game of hollywood types
yeah it's it's
i guess it's the equivalent of johnny
carson's poker game it isn't
it's dungeons and dragons right so we
all used to play poker we were all guys
who used to get together socially and
hang out and smoke cigars and and do our
thing right and now
as kids we all grew up playing this game
and then we all took 25 30 year hiatuses
i didn't touch it for 20 30 25 years
probably
and then um
you know i i was i was trying i was
trying to get the rights to some books
the dungeons and dragons owned when i
was um i had a couple of successful
films at warner brothers i said what do
you want to do next i said i want to do
these books they said do we own them i
said yes you do you have them they
didn't even know no had no idea what are
they all right so i had to like educate
them and then i um a friend of mine from
carnegie mellon a screenwriter named
john castle he and i got together and um
you know i i basically helped him
write um uh a uh we kind of co-wrote i
guess if you call it a spec script to
show them what was possible with this
property and um you know i kept chasing
those books and through chasing those
books i i wound up getting back because
there were executives that were playing
and then they were like come play on
friday friday night we're playing okay
yeah i'm playing years so i went and
played and um
and then i started calling other friends
and
then once people kind of caught wind of
it i would have meetings with executives
who knew that i had this game right and
i would go to sony to talk about some
project and the guy would like close the
door look down the hallway and be like
i used to play when i was a kid you know
like like they're coming out to me
you know and i'm like okay and
but it's really nice
well it's it yeah i mean it i don't know
that much about that so it's not what
stranger things is about now well kind
of i mean the so the kids yeah like the
first scene of stranger things the kids
are playing d and d yeah um but they're
playing this kind of like crazy like you
know crazy version of it but you know my
version for example like the guys who
created game of thrones they play in my
friday night game
really yeah so they don't have to run
the show they don't have to come up with
the story lines they just have to have
their character show up and i they're in
my show and they get to like kick back
and you play for money no you roll dice
and and it's you're it's collaborative
so like for example vince vaughn is in
my game and um you know vince's father i
introduced vince's father like his
character's father into the game and i'd
write these huge monologues and vince
and i just start like
improving and he's speaking to his
father and i'm his father on his death
bed and his father needs to give him
this thing and this piece of information
that they're going to carry with them
and and then there's a huge war going on
and they kind of like figure out their
place within this war and band together
how many people are sitting there in a
game my game is way bigger than ideally
you want four to six mine is 11 and then
i'm the 12th i'm running the game but
it's like everybody wanted to play tom
morello from rage against the machine
was like he's like i gotta get in i'm
like great and then he's like hey this
guy in my kid's carpool wants to play i
go who's your who's the guy and he said
damn he wrote game of thrones i said
yeah all right he can play and then dan
came over
dave threatened to divorce him as a
creative partner if he didn't get david
in my game so then dave joined the big
show the big 744 you know big show paul
white he uh he loves dungeons dragons
when he was a kid he plays he would fly
in from florida charter a jet and come
to the games on friday
and um when you're playing the game you
read these monologues and you yeah i
write them and you know so it's it's
wear a hat you write i do voices i do
you know everything that you you know
you would you would expect
i'm the whole world except for them and
then they get to do whatever they want
which is like chaotic at times have you
ever thought about just recording the
live game yeah that we thought about it
um you know i think a lot of us well see
what happened was i ran into john
favreau at a bob iger party okay
and you know vince and john have been
friends forever and i was like john when
are you coming over to play
and uh of course he turned to sophia and
said you still have sex with him
you know meaning like right here you
know he plays a stupid nerdy game you
know and um and i went come on john i go
come on come over he goes no you know
i'm doing the mandalorian right now and
the mandalorian for me
is dungeon mastering as a kid it's it's
i write the show the way that i did as a
dungeon man so that's the same thing for
me so anyway the point is i want to
getting access to those books that i
wanted
and and and i'm i'm i'm working on the
pilot but this is the journey this is
this is being an actor this is like you
know like she was saying it's like you
know there's hard professions you know i
want to run i want to come circle i want
to come watch dungeons and dragons i
don't want to play
explain to me what i have to do you make
a character based on what like whatever
you want to be what is it like you want
to be a big do you want to be conan do
you want to be merlin do you want to be
gandalf do you want to be a hobbit but
that's what i'm saying do you have to be
something that already exists but
there's a ton of them and and pretty
much if you came up with something under
your head i could figure it out for you
the old jew
we could do that yeah but what does the
old jew do when he
when he's in combat when he fights is he
complains he complains
he says where is there a place to eat he
just you know like he just uh he removes
his foreskin and shoots it at
people into that we can work
and you just chop people in half and it
comes back on yeah we could work this
out yeah really yeah
yeah but is everybody and then do you
have to wear a uh do the the people that
are sitting around this table are they
wearing costumes hell no man come on we
don't do that stuff that's stupid yeah
that's dude i mean people do it and i
don't wanna i don't wanna punch down on
like renaissance fares and things like
that yeah i think you're thinking of
something different dad you're thinking
i don't think you have larping which is
out in the backyard in my monk robes
swinging a foam sword at somebody do you
do that no no i don't know where mine is
i don't know what that is no like listen
this was this is like you know serious
well it's cool you know it's fun and
it's like addictive and it's it's the
fact that you do it and vince vaughn
doesn't you're making what would be
considered it's like john said to you
you know you're still having sex with
him because but overall it's thought to
be incredibly nerdy right well which is
funny because you know there is a
movement a few years ago where
you know i guess it was part of the
feminist movement saying that there was
there were all these gatekeepers in the
1980s who were keeping women from
playing dungeons and dragons and it was
like i would have stuck my arm
in the the belt sander in wood shop to
get a girl to listen to me talk about
touching dresses for 30 seconds like
please you know it just wouldn't happen
girls girls weren't interested in that
time there's tons of girls to play now
you know what i'd love to do i'd love to
watch you just describe it to your wife
oh yeah that's a that's good
have you ever got her into a game of it
never i get about i get like 15 she'll
go did you win and i'll go you know like
she'll ask somebody did you win and
they'll go well we didn't die and um and
then she'll ask me what happened and
i'll start explaining it and she'll go
ahead and just shake her head and really
and if i keep talking she'll go do you
want me to like go upstairs and get my
earring tray and start telling you about
my earrings for 30 minutes and i go all
right fine forget it
really but do you win is there any
there's no end game you don't end yo you
can yeah there's well so like the game
that i was running pre-pandemic that we
ran into the pandemic that we hit time
out on there's this big god at the end
that's trying to take over the world and
there's these cults and minions that
worship them you know that's happening
well it's kind of topical yeah
somebody's ripped from that
and um and they're they're they're
getting closer and closer to this this
big final encounter against this god
where some are going to live some are
going to die we don't know what's going
to happen we don't know how the story is
going to end the the world could be
enslaved or they could they could win
and be heroes wow it sounds like cnn
that's what it sounds like to me who's
don lemon in all of this i don't know
it's your game
you're actually really funny
[Music]
bye